[Music]
i had to change my domain three times in
past five years
during the pandemic
i even had to quit my business
development job due to an injury to my
back
after that
i worked on my recovery for three to
four months
and during that time
i decided to upskill myself
i thought i had to commit to something
if i wanted to grow in life
data analytics was an easy choice for me
because of my long term life goal of
becoming sports and honesty
specifically a football analyst
hi i'm raja vencha
i live in mumbai and i work as data
analyst at edit of technologies at first
i tried to learn from youtube and then
apply for few jobs
but i couldn't crack any then one of my
friends suggested i go for a
certification course with simply
i went through the website and coal
brochures and found it promising
eventually i took the leap of faith and
enrolled in the data analytics
postgraduate program i graduated as a
mechanical engineer in 2017
since then i have worked as design
engineer technical sales engineer and
business development executive
but finally i feel i'm on the right
track now
my overall experience with simplyland
was very good
the teachers were amazing
the response rate and handling of
queries were quick
i got to engage in many projects and i
feel like i was doing more and more
every day since i already knew how to
code i completed all the self-learning
course material in just four months then
one of my friends gave me a freelancing
opportunity in data analytics
and since many of my certificates were
already unlocked as soon as i completed
the freelancing project i thought why
not start applying for the job
within a few days i got three callbacks
two were project manager positions and
one was in data science field i
eventually chose the data science job
even though the pay was slightly lower
i like what i'm doing currently it
doesn't feel like work it feels like
play to me
i feel like cindyland has helped me get
closer to my dream of working with a
football club
as a data analyst it has also helped me
stand out among my peers and rebuild my
confidence in life
i will advise people to go with their
gut and take a leap of faith in life